[Musique]
le corridor jaune ce bout de sable
ni toi ni moi ne pourront le revendiquer
tout ce que je sais en amitié un site
mes fils
tant qu'elles seront sous mon toit je ne
pourrais pas de faire la guerre je les
hais les vrais comme mes propres enfants
avec ma fille la princesse
tu es trop grande maintenant pour jouer
avec les garçons
[Musique]
j'aurais jamais imaginé que tu serais
que tu serais devenu un cyber estime
juan hobeika offre sa fille la princesse
diana
ça oublié à quoi ressemble notre appel
il ressemble à ça arriverait à devenir
riche c'est marc le sultan considère
votre exploitation du corridor jaune
comme une violation du traité
tu es l'émissaire de bk mais avant tout
tu es maintenant monfils est l'époux de
l'inami
[Musique]
r suis venu pour vous alerter et ciba
une armée entraînée avec des armes
modernes
je peux pas me tuer comme ça je suis un
passant tué était un prince ans
[Musique]
l'amour tu me pardonneras de ne pas
étendre les lois de l'hospitalité aux
assassins de mon fils tu es venu au
monde pour régner c'est toi qui sera le
prochain sultan de la citadelle de saint
marc
tu as trahi au même titre qu'elle m'a
trahi moi c'est l'homme le plus
pacifique qu'on puisse imaginer
je crois que tu as trouvé un meilleur
père aussi en équipe
la gaieté pas
maintenant tu es un homme